thank you
good afternoon NATO defense ministers
have just met to address key challenges
for our security
this includes stepping up our support
for Ukraine
strengthening our returns and defense
with forces capabilities and stockpiles
we need and protecting critical
infrastructure with more presence
resilience and intelligence sharing
we addressed Russia's brutal war of
aggression against Ukraine President
Putin has responded to his failures on
the battlefield with attempted
annexations partial mobilization
Reckless nuclear rhetoric and
indiscriminate attacks on civilians and
critical infrastructure
together this represents the most
serious escalation since the invasion in
February
we welcome yesterday's vote in the
United Nations General Assembly
condemning Russia's attempted
annexations and calling for reversal of
these illegal decisions
this is a clear and strong message that
Russia is isolated and the world stands
with Ukraine in defense of the rules
based International order
NATO is not party to the conflict but we
will continue to support Ukraine for as
long as it takes
last night Ukraine's defense minister
Alexia resnikov joined us and gave an
update on the situation on the
battlefield
Ukraine is making good progress
pushing back the invading Russian forces
in the East and in the south
NATO allies are supplying Advanced
systems including artillery air defense
and armored vehicles
and I welcome today's Announcement by
Spain that they will provide four Hawk
launchers to strengthen Ukraine's air
defenses
this comes on top of what other allies
have delivered over the last few days
I thank all allies for the significant
contributions and I urge them to
continue to step up
we're also providing fuel winter
clothing and medical supplies as part of
NATO's comprehensive assistant package
under this package NATO will shortly
deliver counter drone equipment to
Ukraine
with hundreds of drone Jammers which can
help render ineffective Russian and
iranian-made drones
and to protect Ukrainian people and
critical infrastructure
over the longer term we will also help
Ukraine to transition from Soviet era to
Modern NATO equipment
this morning
allies had a regular meeting of the
nuclear Planning Group
it is important we continue to consult
and coordinate on nuclear issues
President Putin's nuclear rhetoric is
dangerous and irresponsible
we takes we take these threats seriously
and we remain vigilant
we will not be intimidated
any use of nuclear weapons would
fundamentally change the nature of the
conflict and have severe consequences
Russia knows that the nuclear war cannot
be won and must now be fought
allies were updated on NATO's long
planned deterrence exercise steadfast
noon which starts next week
this is routine annual training to
ensure NATO's nuclear capabilities
remains safe secure and effective
NATO's nuclear deterrence preserve peace
prevents coercion and deters aggression
minutes is also reviewed our progress on
strength in NATO's Italians and defense
we are increasing the number of high
redness forces we now have more than
more troops in the eastern part of the
Lions including eight NATO battle groups
from the Baltic Sea to the Black Sea
which can be scaled up quickly to
Brigade size
today we took decisions to increase our
stockpiles ominitions and equipment
to speed up the deliverable capabilities
and to use the NATO defense planning
process to provide industry with the
long-term demand they need to boost
production
NATO agencies can also support allies to
facilitate procurement and organize
warehousing for equipment
we also dressed what more we will do to
protect our critical infrastructure
following the sabotage of the nor stream
Pipelines
we have increased our vigilance in the
Baltic and North seas and doubled our
Naval presence there
allies are increasing security
around key installations
and we are stepping up our intelligent
sharing and surveillance across all
domains from space to undersea
capabilities
we also agreed to enhance resilience or
critical undersea and energy
infrastructure including when it comes
to cyber security senior resilience
experts from all allies will meet at
NATO for the first time this year and
address this in detail
in our final session today allies
focused on NATO's missions and
operations from the Western Balkans to
Iraq
we were joined by the EU High
representative Burrell
in a more unpredictable world it is
important to strengthen and deepen NATO
EU cooperation
and I look forward to signing a new
joint declaration with the EU presidents
in the near future
in Bosnia and Herzegovina NATO continues
to support the eu-led operation out
there
and in Kosovo NATO's cave formation
maintains a safe and secure environment
in line with its U.N mandate
in recent months we have seen tensions
flare up on multiple occasions
all parties must behave responsibly show
restraint and avoid violence
you facilitated facilitated dialogue
between Belgard and Krishna is the only
way forward and K for stands ready to
intervene if required
in Iraq NATO remains committed to our
training Mission helping the security
forces to suppress terrorism
NATO remains strong and Vigilant ready
to face any threat from any direction
some of that I'm ready to take your
questions
we'll start with Skye lady in white yeah
um thank you very much thank you um
Secretary General
um the French president has said that
France would not retaliate with nuclear
weapons should Russia launch a nuclear
strike against Ukraine or in the region
would NATO consider a nuclear response
to such an attack and is France
undermining Western deterrence by
unilaterally ruling out a nuclear
response
the fundamental purpose of NATO's
nuclear deterrent is to preserve peace
and deter aggression and prevent
coercion against the NATO allies
circumstances in which NATO might have
to use nuclear weapons are extremely
remote
Russia's nuclear retric is dangerous
Reckless and they know that if they use
nuclear weapon against
uh Ukraine it will have severe
consequences and they also know that a
nuclear war cannot be won an engineered
before
thank you national news agency of
Ukraine Dimitris uh Secretary General
you just mentioned that the exercises
you will have the next week will be
routine one but would you consider some
kind of scenario taking in account the
Russian rhetorics because right now they
are threatening to blow up by the
nuclear weapons the Ukrainian Bridges
but that means the contamination of
soils and Waters which is dangerous not
only for Ukraine for Russia and also for
Europe could that kind of development
trigger the Article 5 thanks
the steadfast noon exercise is a long
plant exercise is an annual exercise it
was planned before the invasion of
Ukraine and we have been transparent on
this and the purpose of that exercise is
to ensure that our nuclear deterrence is
safe secure and affected and this is to
prevent coercion is to prevent
an attack on a NATO Ally it is to
preserve peace because we know that our
nuclear deterrent is our ultimate
deterrence the turns is the way to
prevent any attack on a NATO Ally and to
preserve peace and we have demonstrated
that NATO's nuclear Tyrant is effective
and works we have done that for decades
then
you asked me questions actually about
two different things because one thing
is an attack on NATO allies then we will
of course will trigger Article Five
um
but when it comes to Ukraine NATO is not
parted to the conflict but we support
Ukraine
in defending themselves Ukraine is a
close partner we have been supporting
Ukraine for many years NATO allies have
trained and equipped the Ukrainian
forces since 2014 and of course off the
invasion in in February alas have
stepped up and uh and uh and uh of the
last also months and weeks we have
further delivered further and even more
advanced systems to help you create
protect themselves against the brutality
of the Russian military forces
foreign
Secretary General over the past days
you've said numerous times that you
haven't seen any indications that Russia
may be preparing a nuclear attack
now it's also going to hold its nuclear
exercise soon and in the context of this
I wonder how it will be possible to
distinguish preparations for a
full-scale nuclear exercise from
preparations for a nuclear attack
NATO NATO allies we have very good
intelligence we are working hard we have
a monitor uh monitored Russian nuclear
forces for decades and of course we will
continue to monitor them very closely
and we will stay vigilant uh also when
they're now uh start a new exercise
what I can say is that this exercise the
Russian exercise is an annual exercise
it's uh it's an exercise where they test
and exercise their nuclear forces we
will monitor that as we always do and of
course we will remain Vigilant not least
in light of the
veiled nuclear threats and the dangerous
nuclear rhetoric we have seen from the
Russian side again the purpose of NATO
is to prevent war is to prevent any use
of nuclear weapons and therefore we also
communicating this so clearly also to
Russia
Reuters
Rogers thank you Secretary General a
NATO official yesterday said in case of
a Russian nuclear attack on Ukraine NATO
or NATO allies were almost certain to
respond physically could you explain
that to us what would that mean would
that mean respond with Force
it will have severe consequences if
Russia use nuclear weapon any kind of
you nuclear weapon against the Ukraine
uh and uh this is something Russia knows
uh something NATO and NATO allies have
communicated in different ways to Russia
and uh and we will not go into exactly
how we will respond but of course this
will fundamentally change the nature of
the conflict it will uh it will
mean that a very important line has been
closed uh even any use of a smaller
nuclear weapon will be a very serious
thing a fundamentally changing the
nature of the war in Ukraine and of
course that will have consequences and
Russia knows there will be a
consequences
the Army phone from Ukraine here in the
middle
thank you Paul McClary with Politico uh
Russia has attacked civilian Targets in
Ukraine from the start of the war but
it's really ramped up this week
do you think these attacks are
deliberate and do they constitute war
crimes
we have seen throughout the whole war
attacks on civilians we have seen
horrific attacks on on
civilian infrastructure on hospitals on
on on residential areas and we have seen
a high number of Civilian casualties
and of course any deliberate attack on
civilians constitute a war crime that's
also the reason why it is so important
to now support the ongoing
investigations NATO allies are providing
support to Ukraine so they can collect
facts
um
make available all the documentation
which is uh necessary and then this is
important to ensure that those who are
responsible are held accountable for war
crimes committed in Ukraine
Wall Street Journal
Dan Michael's Wall Street Journal
um winter is going to make warfighting
hard for both sides I does Ukraine have
enough support in the particular
equipment it needs from NATO members and
from the contact group to continue
pushing its recent offensives throughout
the Winter thank you that's the main
message from from the meetings in
Brussels today and yesterday in in the
NATO defense ministerial meeting and and
the U.S led contact group was to
mobilize more support for Ukraine not
least in light of the fact that the
winter is coming so there has been a lot
of focus on winter clothing on on
equipment to enable them to also operate
throughout the winter generators tent
and and other things which are extremely
important to enable the Ukrainian forces
to operate also throughout the winter
then I think it will I will leave it to
the Ukrainian commanders to comment
exactly on how they will operate but our
task is to enable them to also be able
to conduct meaningful operations
throughout the winter and continue to
supply them with everything from fuel
winter clothing tents to advance the
weapon systems air defense
armored vehicles and advanced artillery
okay we'll now go to Army from Ukraine
gentlemen with glasses
yes good afternoon I mean from what
we'll need to do to help to protect
Ukraine's Finance infrastructure and the
military to Outlaw the war
on late we'll step up what NATO NATO
allies and partners are now done for
several months we have already delivered
unprecedented support to Ukraine and
this has helped the ukrainians to make
the gains they are made over the last
weeks in in the war
against the invading Russian forces of
course the victories we have seen in
kharkeep and in Carson
they belong to the brave Ukrainian
soldiers but the support that NATO NATO
allies and importance have provided has
enabled them to make these gains and and
and we will continue and deliver even
more ammunition weapons and all and also
of course air defense systems pointed to
protected forces the critical
infrastructure but also to protect
civilians I trust that the Ukrainian
commanders know how to best utilize the
different air defense systems we are
delivering but you have to understand
that just over the last few days we are
having announcements and deliveries from
countries like the United States uh
Germany just announced the actually
delivered a very Advanced air defense
system Spain announced a new delivery of
uh of Hawk air defense launches today
and
and France has announced
more air defense to Ukraine so also the
Netherlands and many other countries so
just over the last few days we have seen
that when we mobilize when we call our
NATO allies to do more they're actually
doing more and that's making a huge
difference and that was also the main
topic we discussed with the defense
ministeristnikov and of course he calls
us to do more eye colon allies we all
call and allies and others are not
digging deeper into their stocks to be
able to provide more support to Ukraine
at the same time them deeper we dig into
existing NATO stocks the more important
is that we also are able to ramp for
production so that has been the other
main issue of the meetings today is how
to ensure that our industry are
producing more partly by utilizing
existing production capacity more more
shifts more weekend and more just to
utilize existing
Investments more but then there are
there also obvious need to invest more
to expand the production capacity so we
are prepared for long-haul both to be
able to replenish our own stocks for our
own returns and defense but also to
enable us to continue to support Ukraine
because
[Music]
of all uh please uh can you give us more
details on what you discussed on Western
Balkans especially with regards to
cooperation with European Union
um first of all the Western Balkans is a
region in Europe where the European
Union and NATO are working very closely
together
um of course we work together in in
Boston now where
NATO supports the eu-led uh operational
Fair we all work hard for an extension
of the U.N mandate for that operation
and the NATO headquarters in Southern
Iowa is working closely with the EU
personnel and the euf offices and also
operational theater in Boston
NATO of course has a long history in the
western Balkans we hope to end the two
brutal Wars first one in Boston
we have our presence the k for mission
in Kosovo allies are committed to um to
continue to contribute forces that we
made some new announcements from some
countries to step up support for our K4
Mission and we have seen increased
tensions in in Kosovo not least elected
to this license plate issue and again we
see how NATO troops Decay for troops
support the efforts of the EU diplomats
to make progress on the EU facilitated
positional balgar dialogue so and then
of course we have many members in in the
western Balkan region and NATO has
actually recently actually
we have two new members from from the
region
Montenegro and North Macedonia and
demonstrating NATO store is open and
that we are further strengthening our
relationship with that region foreign
there is no internal political consensus
in Boston and Herzegovina to joining the
NATO aliens that's a big challenge how
do you see that issue and how close are
we to joining the NATO thank you
is one of the
countries that have um which are on the
path towards a NATO membership and of
course we will continue to support the
efforts of Boston and so Governor to
move closer towards NATO and we we work
and we support those efforts then at the
end of the day of course it has to be
Boston that decides whether it wants to
join it or not that's for uh that's been
contribution and for the 30 allies to
decide soon to be actually at 32 with
Finland and Sweden no one else but of
course it has to be something that this
wanted Bible says NATO always respect
Decisions by countries to choose their
own path so if a country wants to be
neutral we of course 100 respect that if
they want to join NATO of course then we
sit down and see what we can do to make
them move towards a NATO membership
okay we'll take one final question from
polish TV lady in blue
I want to ask you do you consider a risk
of new provocation on the border between
Poland or Lithuania and Belarus at what
might be answered of NATO in the case of
new Belarusian provocation On the Border
or Russian thank you
when The Invasion happened in February
NATO was well prepared because we had
intelligence
telling us clearly that the invasion was
under preparation and something that was
going to come we actually shared that
intelligence with the broader public as
well as last fall so when the invention
happened we were prepared meaning that
with the same warning were able to
activate our defense bans and
increase further our presence in eastern
part Alliance so we were not surprised
and I said this because
we are actually been preparing for a
situation like this since 2014. since
2014 we have a
implemented the biggest reinforcement of
collective events since the end of the
Cold War therefore we were able to
deploy thousands of new troops in the
eastern part of Alliance also to Poland
backed by significant Naval and Air
Forces and we have increased the redness
of our forces to be able to further
reinforce if needed we also made the
decisions in Madrid that will further
strengthen NATO's Collective defense I
say all this because the purpose of this
increased military presence is to
prevent any misunderstanding or
miscalculation about NATO's redness to
protect every initial Ally territory and
the reason why we repeat and repeat
again and again this message is that as
long there is no miscalculation in any
capital of any potential adversary then
they will not attack us
because we are the strongest Alliance in
in history of course there's always a
risk for hybrid attacks for cyber
attacks but the arm the armed attack on
the NATO Allied country uh well uh we
have been able to protect against that
for more than 70 years because we have
been United and because we have been
able to every day
um uh send the care message of the
Terence that we uh are one for all all
for one that I'll collected offense
calls is real
thank you very much this concludes this
press conference
thank you